we ship recalled Samaritans yeah I think  you've got something already there  command are you receiving me  there's no music you're the music  whose debut album you've got a vinyl  release I love your stuff I thought this  girl you know my damage this is a huge  opportunity I've got a line of  songwriters down the hall trying to  write for Dana Lee Erin wants me to  write with Allie how cool I just don't  see it's just being like a cog in a big  machine Darren I love her I love her I  want her can I have her you know when a  singer finds a writer they think sounds  like them they hang on for less come on  I want my next hit this is weighty Kevin  you can hear that transmission I scare  people  that's nice I like that we've  constructed like a whole made-up world  and it stops us from seeing everything  it really is stop thinking what if you  can put that into your work then you can  accomplish something really great  [Music]  you  [Music]  you